hello everybody
so as an except my name is Yuna it
sounds like unicorn this is not the
unicorn emoji but there will be unicorn
emoji so that's super exciting I am a
friends elver at the bluemix teemed iBM
has started this a CDC meetup nhx ass
meetup and I'm also a member of the open
design foundation but more importantly I
found this perfect tweet describe what I
do from Horst is and what I do is just
breaking the web with CSS and this talk
is a perfect example of that so if
you're here to see some breaking the web
welcome welcome to get you in the mood I
have a video here I thought you was
getting to be a lady Photoshop it's
gonna be a pleasure to kill you or less
than your chrome in this presentation
give me a lesson in long distance
spitting anything you can do I can do
better I can do anything better than you
are you yes I can oh you can yes I can
oh you can yes I can yes I can all right
so now that you'll feel me now they were
all in the mood for this let's get
excited so last week I was in Vilonia
that is a huge thing of tiramisu it's
it's ridiculous how they feed you there
like it's insane I didn't eat it hello
and I promise but anyway while I was in
Bologna I won do some traveling so I go
online and go the Train Italia website I
don't speak Italian I'm so sorry
so I just had to translate the page for
Italian to English a translate of the
page
I still see Oh God I still see this I
could have blacked out um so here I am
wondering what does this say I thought
I'd translated the page why is there a
baby I just want to buy a train pass to
visit another city I've no idea what
saying and I get really frustrated
because this is an example of a designer
just throwing it like a comp together in
Photoshop and putting it online like
this isn't helping anybody here at CSS
comp we have over 31 countries
represented
that's amazing like coming clap for the
organizer is really quick for that
Oh like this isn't going to help any of
those people fine talk about loading
time so the average loading time for
Photoshop is 33 seconds but my favorite
part of this is not just we have to wait
and watch the slowed screen that we have
nightmares of they also want to
highlight the names of the people
responsible for this while we wait cool
thank you it's fine let's talk about
responsive design in photoshop we're
done talking about it
you came down with like a separate
application you could fake it but you
really can't do responsive design like
you can do in the browser and then the
price okay that's a lot of money it's
240 dollars a year just for Photoshop
alone I created cloud the six hundred US
dollars a year it's quite a bit but it's
fine cuz I can go to flaming text calm
and just make all of these logos look I
have like 20 logo options right now I
had to pay zero dollars and zero cents
for Google Chrome and this is the worst
part so I remember trying to sign in to
browser what I'm - Photoshop while I was
on an airplane I was trying to do some
work so it's exciting required that's
fine I'm trying to sign up my team and
then I get please connect to the
Internet and retry I'm on an airplane I
don't have Wi-Fi so what do I do I hit
cancel are you sure you want to quit yes
I want to quit and then this is how I
feel about Photoshop from now on oh gosh
so this talk is going to focus on
filters and blend modes specifically and
we're also going to talk about gradients
a little bit but there is a vast variety
of things that you can do in the browser
instead of opening Photoshop to do them
cutting images out there's so much so
I'm just going to be focusing on these
few topics and before I move on just a
notes normally I would be using
something like post-assessment
autoprefixer to take care of my vendor
prefix thing but I'm using just a style
block with constant editable and this
demo and just vanilla CSS so I'm going
to have to do some WebKit filter
prefixing so just keep that in mind you
won't actually do that in real life so
starting with CSS filters the
compatibility with CSS filters is pretty
good the only browser that's really not
doing it yet is edge but um hopefully
that will change so here I can seem a
little bit there we go
so the options that we have for CSS
filters are blur brightness contrast
drop shadow grayscale hue rotate invert
opacity CPN saturate so we have a few
different options here and just to show
an example here some of the more
interesting ones I find are like drop
shadow because it takes this shape of
that image so here we have a PNG and if
I move this out a little bit you can
really see that this drop shadow is
taking the shape of that image so
instead of a box shadow that just takes
the size of the box or it takes the
border size it will just take the size
of that image itself so that's pretty
cool
blur does what you would think it does
it works with any really unit value here
so we could do like 0.2 m/s if we want
any any unit value here so brightness
obviously anything that is greater than
one for brightness will increase the
brightness and anything less will
decrease it so a brightness of zero just
makes it black another interesting one
that I will talk about the highlight
here is invert so invert also takes no
parameters so if you have no parameters
in there it takes it as value of one
completely inverts your image here if
it's an invert value of 0.5 its
completely gray scaled because the way
that you invert pixels is you take the
luminance value and you subtract it from
one so right here when you do invert
point five you're taking all the
luminance values and setting them
closest to that 50% gray so the rest are
kind of self-explanatory grayscale key
rotate is another fun one that I can
highlight so this you can play with so
here's like zero degrees and then I
could do like 180 degrees rotates the
hue of that color just on a circular
plane by the degree that you basically
set it to here so you can solve a lot of
really small problems by using filters
very briefly this is a blog post that I
wrote and I use the paper app so I use
the paper app and what happens in use
the paper app is you get this grey
background but I wanted to flow into
this white background a little bit on my
page so I just set this WebKit filter
and as you can see all the images here
do have that gray
but instead of opening all these images
in Photoshop editing them all
individually I just had to add a WebKit
filter or just a regular filter of
brightness 1.1 I could have used a
contrast filter and it just makes it
flow a lot better into this document one
line of code beautiful thank you CSS
filters you can also have some fun with
it because this CSS you can do fun
things like animate this is literally
five lines of code I'm using a hue
rotate animation and it's creating this
visualization just super quick super
easy and something that's inherent to us
so blend modes this is where things
start to get really interesting so there
are two types background blend mode and
mix blend mode and background blend mode
works on the background items within the
element so if an element has multiple
backgrounds you can use this to kind of
channel how those different backgrounds
interact with each other so the support
on this is a little worse than filters
em edge again doesn't really have much
but it's getting there so mixed blend
mode is very similar with sports and
this takes that element itself and talks
about how it's going to blend in with
the other elements on the page behind it
so all the blend mode options that we
have in Photoshop are listed here
and CSS has a majority of these so I'm
going to kind of walk through how those
work a little bit so the blend mode
types there are five different types
there's the darken modes group there are
light modes contrast modes Comparative
modes and composite modes so I'm going
to use my balloon friend here to help me
explain this Munsell color system with
web color names here so as you can see
there is a rainbow projected on this
balloon and if you look at these lights
from the top of the stage it's the
lightness value that's the luminosity so
stranding it down the light and it kind
of becomes a cone of darkness at the
bottom now you can see the whole range
of colors surrounding the balloon and
the very inside of the balloon that
Center Point's is a 50% gray so no
matter what the line light can't shine
in all the way it becomes a 50% gray you
still have light from the top coming
down so the most saturated value is what
this balloon gets from that light
projecting immediately thank you to the
awesome light team here I also give them
around
let's keep that up there because they'll
help explain the blend modes when I keep
going but I figured I might as well take
a bloon off the loan use it while I have
the opportunity so to explain dark and
blend modes I'm going to use the help of
vanilla ice and vanilla ice cream so
let's start with multiply ok we're
multiplying them are going to overlap
our images so the way that multiplied
works is it uses the luminance levels
that light level of the pixels in each
space of these two images and it just
multiplies the pixels um math terms it
just does a times B and this is a lot
like transparency so if you take Juve
entrace perón seized and overlay them
and then shine a light through that's
what the multiply blend mode does so if
your pixel value is 1 if luminosity is 1
it shines all the way through but the
more you layer the darker it gets so
darken works in a similar way except it
uses the RGB values so if not as dark
because it's using the color range on a
per color a per channel basis to sort of
detect which colors should remain which
which leaves so if the active layer
pixels the active layer is the ice cream
here I'm only applying the blend mode to
that active layer if those pixels are
darker than they stay but if they're
lighter than the tones of pixels behind
them they're replaced by those tones the
last one is color burn which is the most
saturated of all of these and it also
uses the luminance values but it uses an
inversion algorithm to sort of have that
more saturated look so for lighten blend
modes we're gonna have a dog surfing and
a dog skateboarding who's the winner
here so screen blend mode is the
opposite of the multiply blend mode it
is inverting the pixel so how like I
mentioned earlier it's doing 1 minus
that luminosity value and then it's
multiplying that for both the active and
background layer and then inverting the
product of that so it's inverting it
again and this basically means that
we're multiplying the light pixels so
then lighten is using those RGB values
it's not as bright as screen and color
Dodge is the brightest so blows things
out the quickest of all of these
lightening blend modes now once we have
the contrast group so here we're gonna
do oatmeal and a comic from the oatmeal
I really worked hard in these puns yell
alright so we're gonna do overlay so one
thing that the contrast group is a uses
a combination of lighten and darken
modes in different ways
and so for over like for example
specifically it uses both the screen and
the multiply blend mode both in half
strength and it takes those mid-tones
50% gray and just drops them so that's
how that works
soft play is a little more organic it
keeps those 50% mid-tones and then hard
light is the most dramatic so they all
sort of work in similar ways with the
contrast group comparative blend modes
are next and so we have an oreo rainbows
this is my favorite group and then Tim
Tams for all the Australians here it's a
Tim Tam fridge I wanted to bridge the
gap because I want Tim Tams in America
anyway let's make that happen with
difference oh my gosh so this group does
something pretty fun so it basically
takes pixels that are on the same space
of the two values and it inverts the
pixels based on the luminance channels
on a channel by channel basis so you
take the active layer pixel and you
subtract it from the same layer on the
background pixel and for difference is
selective inversion where similar colors
will turn black they'll cancel each
other out and turn black but it inverts
it so the original point and use case of
difference was lining up transparencies
when you had the perfect black on black
that's how you knew that things were
perfectly aligned exclusion is pretty
similar to difference but it has those
50% gray mid-tones so it's a little bit
lighter than the difference blend mode
and then we have one last group and
that's the composite one mode that's why
I'm glad that my friends Klaus here is
helping so we've got the Wi-Fi password
pretty much so we got cat pictures as
promised and pupae laces um so this is
kind of interesting what happens here is
with the active layer so the lasers it
only takes a hue it keeps that hue color
that's mixing it with both the
luminosity and the saturation of the
background layer so since the cats are
so bright it keeps that bright white so
I'm taking the hue and since they're not
very saturated
you shade is going to become lighter I'm
over top of the cats in this demo
example so saturation only takes a
saturation of lasers so it takes the
colors of the cat so their eyes become a
very bright blue their fur becomes very
very saturated but the value the color
value remains and so does the luminosity
so luminosity is going to look a little
different than all of these this one is
taking just luminosity so the basically
the blacks and whites of laser image and
imposing the cat's coloring on top of
that the hue and then my favorite of all
these is the color blend mode so this is
really cool because it uses both the hue
and saturation of the active layer so of
those lasers and slurring it on top of
just luminosity of the cats so in
essence it's like taking a
black-and-white photograph and
overlaying that with a color image but
the best part is the photograph doesn't
have to be black and white because the
browser is doing that for us
it's making it happen so anything you
can just use to color on top of an image
with the mixed blend mode of color so
you can do a lot of really fun
techniques if we look at that example
again of the header that I made for that
blog post something that we can do is
add like a mix blend mode of multiply
and it starts to really blend that
background this could be any color this
could be like a that's a blue color okay
that's cool we'll keep it at say a
purple um so we can make it multiply but
remember how it wasn't exactly white we
still had to do a WebKit filter to
increase the brightness or the contrast
let's do the contrast like one point one
and there it's flowing perfectly in with
the background we can do a hero Tate
some of those shapes might start to
change color we can really start to
dynamically play around with this just
like in the browser is probably more
like 130 degrees like that changes
another option is we can do a screen
blend mode which is the opposite of
multiply like we went over and then we
would have to go in and invert that so
you can really start to play around with
things just dynamically in your browser
and you can be super lazy about it
in fact I call the filet Z designer
method
so there are two parts to this the first
one is you use the blend mode of
multiply or screen and then you isolate
the graphic with contrast filters and
possibly the physical shape of it so as
an example here's a picture I took them
belong here from the rooftop of the
hotel last week super cool and I just
have a little hello waving back and
forth but if we really dissect this
you'll see what's going on in the
background so let's make a little bit
bigger because I cut down the size five
minutes to bake so 300 by maybe the
height of 400 and then you start to
think like what is that it's not fun
little hello that I thought it was let's
get rid of that multiply blend mode okay
let's get rid of the WebKit filter we
can give her the positioning so if you
take a look it's me holding up a random
coaster at a bar that I took a picture
of and I overlaid it on top of a graphic
and you can't tell it all with that lazy
designer Messick's and using blend modes
and filters it's pretty cool another
example of this thank you
being lazy here's another example of
this but I use the screen blend mode so
I took this random little sketch I could
just reload the browser thing um and
here's me I'm doing that it's a sketch
for my sketchbook I am using these same
technique but with screen and just comes
in elements in the page and allows for a
really nice flow awesome websites that
use blend modes for instance front and
London they have this really nice
gradient of hot pink to red on this page
and you can even use it for um
performance optimization because you can
use just a grayscale image that
background for the JPEG decrease the
color size decrease the image size and
use blend modes to like make this
dynamic and really interesting
composition regardless of the images
that you have in there
another example is polygons they have a
really unique look on their homepage for
this news story it's not something that
you see often these days but it's really
nice aesthetic to see and then the xoxo
conference uses blend modes and my
favorite part blend modes is you can
scroll around you can animate them you
can really make this dynamic and
exciting for your user it's such a
little thing that allows for a much more
unique aesthetic let's go back in time
for a little bit back to the days of
deviantART does anyone here do
deviantART yeah awesome so back in the
day I remember I would go on and I would
look for Photoshop actions and here was
like this description I don't don't read
that it's way too much text please don't
read it so anyway I wanted to start week
Rainey's Photoshop actions so um I found
one that sounded interesting
raging mists offers the most faded
outlook of all of these it fades out
images with purple hues and warmer tones
to create a sultry vintage effect sound
sultry let's do it all right so let's
recreate raging this filter that's the
raging mist filter and that's our
original image so let's start the first
thing that we can do is use some filters
so WebKit filter like I'm using a sepia
because I see some more warm tones I'm
going to do a hue rotate to start
getting it there maybe increase the
saturation okay so that's great that's
on the image itself that's step one step
two is adding a layer on top so I'm
going to show you the have a layer on
top of here with a background color
I'll start with red so you could see it
okay so I didn't lie there's something
up there
and so now I want to do a mix blend mode
of maybe like multiply so it's laying on
top of that image but that's not exactly
the color that we want as a know so what
you can do is open your dev tools and
use it like a browser pretty much like
Photoshop you can use a really nice
color selector here you can change the
the Alpha Channel and you can even
select from the page to start getting
that aesthetic that we want like I can
just keep clicking around maybe if I
don't like that color I could edit it a
little bit but it's starting to really
look like the image that we want to get
for the final so that's good and there's
only one step left if we really look at
this raging mist example here I have to
remove it more you'll notice that in the
darkest parts we're losing some detail
in the shadow there's sort of this wash
over it it's like a washout effect it's
like this vintage it's a little bit
purpley gray effect there so let's make
that happen this is what I like to call
the washout effect method got some nice
methods for you the first step is to use
the blend mode of lighten and after
we've done that we want to use a
background color of the shadow colors
the darkest color that we want to appear
on our image so here's an example of
doing that so to set the background mode
to lighten and then I am choosing this
secondary background so those are just
two backgrounds comma separated values
and as I go lighter the background
becomes lighter and then I can choose
that darkest color that I want to appear
on the page every other color will get
washed out so let's do that so all right
I have my first background here let's
make other backgrounds of red for
instance and like I said we're going to
do a background blood mode of lighten
okay so that's not exactly the shade
that we want it's washing out a little
too much so again I'm going to inspect
element I'm going to find this image
find that red and sort of just set it to
like a deeper hue maybe like a purpley
washout tone I think that looks pretty
close so I'm going to keep that I have
this value here and yeah that looks
pretty good
for the region that's filtered
not bad it could be worse but it could
be better so let's kick it up a notch
the CSS gradients okay so I'm going to
go through this really quickly based
gradients you just can do a linear
gradient set to colors it starts at the
50% mark so I'm using this pink color
see 69 which is the sass color so I like
to use that for everything and then the
second goal area is like this blue shade
so it's basic gradient you can change
the directions I could do two right I
could do like two left to top to bottom
whatever I can change those directions I
can do degrees so here I've negative
twenty degrees I could do like 120
degrees it changes the direction of that
gradients you can also open the dev
tools here and watch it spin which is
really fun because you can just hit
shift and arrow key and it'll like spin
for you so that's something that I have
no life alright so the next thing that I
want talk about is the gradient stops
these are fun a cool thing is like the
further you go towards these stops you
can actually make like stripes so if I
keep going I set these both to 30 like
that makes a solid line because it's
fewer and fewer pixels for a gradient to
occur on and then what you can do is you
can make like repeating gradients so you
could make stripes across your page
these are really fun for backgrounds and
other such things we have the radial
gradients so this takes the shape of the
element that it's contained within but
you can also set the shape of that
radial so I can make it a circle I can
say like I want it to be like a 200 by
30 pixel weird shape and you have a lot
of control with this as well and there's
also stripes the good news I could do a
repeating radial gradient so if I wanted
those solid stripes what I could do is
set like the start color so start C 69
I'm going to end let's make this pixel
so it's easier to see ten pixels the
next color starting at ten pixels and
then I'm going to have it ending at that
same color maybe I want this 30 pixels
wide so now I have this crazy gradients
to circle so it's not so crazy but yeah
you could just do radial stripes and
play around CSS is so much fun I'm so
sorry
so sorry so conic gradients are really
cool I think Lea's go talking about them
later go check that out or just stay in
this room listen to our talk I cannot
wait to watch this so that's the thing
to look forward to later all right
so this is an example of just using
those blend modes with the gradient so
here just basic image here is the just
the gradient I'm applying to it and it
creates all of these image variations
I'm just so many different aesthetics by
playing around and they all look pretty
good I could have probably chosen any of
these but wait there's more double fam
all right I'm going to take you back in
the day again to the days of these um
free blurry backgrounds so blurry
backgrounds are really cool right we all
kind of use them we can break that down
and make them ourselves
you know why open Photoshop and make one
when we can make these with gradients so
you can break it down and look at that
one it has this magenta to royal blue
color there's like this purple spot the
bottom there's a sweet spot the top
maybe some angled gradients of this like
tomato and light blue color this is why
I'm really good a named CSS colors I
don't know it's not a good thing fine
okay so let's zoom in and make this
thing happen all right so there's the
final product that we're going for
here's our background what's going to
happen I think a good place to start is
with this linear gradient that goes from
like a hot pink to blue okay so there's
that but we don't want to go from top to
bottom we want to go to right so let's
make it go to right maybe this is more
like a deep pink I don't like I said I
don't know why I know all these color
names it's fine okay so that's a good
place to start I think the next best
thing is to make that light spot the top
so it's like this creamy color so we'll
do a radial gradient at the top and
it'll be from like wheat to transparent
we want a comma okay so that's that's
cool and we want to be at top so I can
say where I want you positioned at and
maybe I want this to be a circle at the
top or maybe I want to specify the shape
of it I think the circle is okay for now
and I wanted to be a little bit offset
in the page so I could be like negative
10% is the start of that and I
want to end at like 80% okay so we're
starting to sort of get there okay so
next maybe beneath that we have this
this tomato color so we have a linear
gradient and I know that it's going to
be at a degree so maybe like 160 degrees
and it could be tomato it's going to be
transparent I'm going to add a comma all
right so that's starting to look more
like what we have but to save you all
this pressure watching me go through all
of it I've already done it look at that
so what's really exciting about this is
it's super powerful for creating your
own customized filters you can create
anything when you use this technique and
I use it on this site I used a very
similar one to the one I just showed you
and it adds this really unified
aesthetic to this page so without them
these images are kind of boring and they
blend into the background doesn't look
that good but if I add a custom filter
that I make out of these gradients it
really brings them together and unifies
them on the page so you can make
Instagram filters very very quickly and
easily pretty pretty easily so here's a
picture of the office area of my
apartment and I use this an example so
like rays Aiden I just did these for fun
Inc well the cool thing about that is I
don't even have to use another after
element to add some kind of blend mode I
just used WebKit filters for that one
and then for Perpetua I didn't use any
WebKit filters I just used a blend mode
afterwards
it's like this blue to gray blue degree
and sort of fake so let's review because
we're at the end here CSS filters plus
CSS blend modes plus CSS gradients equal
awesome and in conclusion CSS is awesome
like you can't do this in Photoshop you
can't have this hero chain animation in
a presentation and Photoshop very easily
I don't think don't tell me I'm wrong
but this is just the beginning like this
is really exciting like this Barbie
alright now we're at this very basic
Mario game but soon we're going to be at
like Super Mario 3d World
you know when browser start to really
implement these and make them work
really well with our GPUs it's really
good to just start playing around now so
I say art the web if you make something
cool this talk inspired you use the
hashtag art the web start to use these
things in your own personal projects or
in production I sort of played around
with it on this site that I made I do a
little bit of traveling and I write
about it sometimes I call it bad poetry
of good memories and if you want to go
to it it sort of was like a tester for
some of the concepts I talked about in
this talk so I'm using some different
things like she sees shapes and I'm
using some of the filters and blend
modes looks way better on your browser
in chrome 44 I know I don't care it's
fine
fine just a Chester so don't be like I
can't see this Nighy I know you can't
see tonight
I know so thank you so much for having
me and thank you like
you